The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: He ended up last
Thursday's lectures talking
about Gaussian distributions.
As he said, one of the
interesting things about a
Gaussian is it can be fully
characterized by its mean and
its standard deviation.
And this concept of being
able to take a curve and
characterize it with a small
number of parameters is
something we'll continue to see
as a very important way of
looking at modeling
physical systems.
And in fact, that is
the part of the
term that we've entered.
And it's a part of the term
we'll spend a lot of time on.
And the whole issue is, how do
we construct computational
models that will help us
understand the real world?
When we can, we love to model
distributions as Gaussians, or
normal, because they're so
nicely characterized.
We have nice rules of thumb that
tell us how close things
lie to the mean, et cetera.
However, it's important to
understand that if something
is not actually normally
distributed and we pretend it
is, we can get very misleading
results out of our model.
So let's think about the
fact that not all
distributions are normal.
So consider rolling
a single die.
Each of the 6 outcomes
is equally probable.
So we would not expect to see a
peak, say, at 3 or 4, and a
trough at 1.
A 3 or a 4 is the same
probability as 1.
Similarly, if one thinks about
the Massachusetts state
lottery, or any fair lottery,
the probability of each number
coming up is the same.
So it would be a flat line.
If you had a million numbers,
the probability of each number
is 1 over a million.
And so if you plotted the
probability of each number,
again, you'd get a flat line.
Such distributions are
called uniform.
Each result is equally
probable.
We can fully characterize a
uniform distribution with a
single parameter, its range.
If I tell you it ranges over 1
to a million, that's all you
need to know to know what the
distribution looks like.
So they're even simpler than
normal distributions.
Uniform distributions occur
quite often in games devised
by humans, but almost
never in nature.
And typically they're
not very useful for
modeling complex systems.
We have to work hard to invent
something that's normal.
Most things are not naturally
that way.
I'm sorry, to invent things
that are uniform.
Normal, as we saw last time,
occurs all the time in nature.
The other thing that occurs
quite frequently are
exponential distributions.
They're used in a lot
of different ways.
For example, people who are
trying to plan things like
highway systems use exponential
distributions to
model inter-arrival times, how
much time there is between
each car, say, entering
the Mass Turnpike.
We'll see many other
examples of them.
The key thing about them is
they have the property of
being memoryless.
They are in fact the only
continuous distributions that
are memoryless.
So let's look at an example
with which some of you are
more familiar than you want to
be, the concentration of a
drug in the human body.
For those who are watching on
OpenCourseWare, it's not
because all the students
are drug users.
It's because they're working on
a problem set that involves
modeling drugs in
the human body.
I don't know how many of you
are drug users, all right?
Assume that at each time step,
each molecule has a
probability p of being
cleared by the body.
The system is memoryless in the
sense that at each step,
the probability of a particular
molecule being
cleared is independent
of what happened at
the previous steps.
So the fact that a molecule
didn't get cleared at time t
has no impact on whether
or not it will be
cleared at time t1.
The probability doesn't go up
as it doesn't get cleared.
So it's independent of
the previous steps.
So at time t equals 1, what's
the probability of the
molecule still being
in the human body?
If the probability of being
cleared at each step is p,
it's 1 minus p, right?
So if the probability of being
cleared was 0.5 at each time
step, the time that it still
exists after the first time
step is 1 minus 0.5--
i.e., 0.5.
So what's the probability of
it still being in the human
body at time t equals 2?
Well, it wasn't cleared
at time 1.
Since it's memoryless, whether
or not it's cleared at time 2
is also 1/p.
And so it existing still after
two steps is going to be 1
minus p squared.
We saw that with independent
probabilities.
And the nice thing about working
with exponential
distributions is we know that
the probabilities are
independent.
More generally, its still being
in the body at time t is
going to be 1 minus
p to the t.
So we have a nice closed-form
solution that will give us the
probability of each molecule
surviving until time t.
All right?
So now let's look at the
question of, suppose that at
time t equals 0, there
are m0 molecules.
Now we can ask, how many
molecules are there likely to
be at any time t?
Well, let's write a little
program to look at that.
So that's this program, clear.
We'll start with n, the number
of molecules, the probability
of clearing it at each step,
and the number of steps.
And we'll keep track of
the num remaining.
So at the beginning, we have
n molecules remaining.
And then for t in range steps,
we're just going to multiply
n, the number we started with,
times the probability of each
molecule still existing.
And then we'll plot it.
Does that make sense?
So this is a tiny bit of code
that basically implements that
formula over on the board.
Let's run it.
And we'll run it starting with
a 1,000 molecules, a
probability of each being
cleared of 0.01, and we'll
look at 500 time steps.
All right.
This is kind of interesting.
We're getting a straight line.
That doesn't look like an
exponential, does it?
Or does it?
Why do we have a straight
line here?
Somebody?
Because I used a semilog axis.
So let's look at it
now without that.
We now see something that
really does look like
exponential decay.
It drops very quickly in the
beginning, and then it
asymptotes towards 0.
But of course it never
quite gets there in
a continuous model.
If we had a discrete model, we
would eventually have to get
to 0, because that last molecule
would either get
cleared or not.
But in a continuous world--
which is in this case probably
not a good model, or not a
perfect model I should say,
because it allows us to have a
quarter of a molecule there,
which we kind of know is
physiologically nonsense,
biochemically nonsense.
But you can see we get this
exponential decay.
But as we saw previously, if
we plot an exponential on a
log axis, as the math
would tell us, we
get a straight line.
And that, in fact, is a very
simple and nice way to see
whether you have an exponential
distribution.
Put it on a log axis, see
if it's straight.
It's a good trick, and
one we use a lot.
OK.
So there, I took the physical
model I described and derived,
through a little bit of math,
what the result should be, and
implemented some code
to give us a plot of
what that told us.
Let's look at a different
way of doing it.
I could've instead written a
Monte Carlo simulation to do
the same kind of thing.
So here, instead of working out
the probabilities, I just
tried to write some code that
exactly mimicked the physical
process that I was
talking about.
So instead of knowing that I
could just look at 1 minus p
to the t, at each step, I
cleared some molecules.
I just used random.random.
If I came out with something
less than the clear
probability, I got rid
of that molecule.
And I did that for each
molecule, deciding whether or
not it should be cleared.
For molecule m in range, looking
at all the remaining
molecules, I either clear
one or I don't.
And then I can plot that.
So let's look what happens if
I compare the two results.
So I'm going to do the original
analytical model of
clear, and then the simulation
model of clearing, and see
what I get.
Well, much to my relief, I get
kind of the same curve.
Not exactly.
You'll notice that the blue
curve, the analytical model,
is a beautiful smooth curve,
whereas the red curve has got
a little bit of jaggies.
It's clearly very similar
to the blue
curve, but not identical.
It doesn't surprise me.
There is some randomness
in there.
And in fact, I could have gotten
unlucky and gotten
something that didn't look
like the blue curve.
But given the sample size, that
would have been quite
surprising.
Which of these two models
do you like better?
So we've got two models.
We've got one I'll call the
analytic model, and one I'll
call the simulation model.
Both show exponential decay.
That is to say the number
of molecules declines
exponentially, quite quickly.
But they're not quite
identical.
So which would we prefer?
Or which would you prefer?
There is no right
answer for this.
Just for fun, I'll
ask for a poll.
Who prefers the analytical
model?
Who prefer the simulation?
All right.
Somebody who prefers the
analytical, tell me why.
AUDIENCE: It looks
a lot nicer.
PROFESSOR: Well, all right.
It looks a lot nicer.
That's kind of human
nature, to prefer
something that looks prettier.
On the other hand, what we're
really interested in is the
question of not aesthetics,
but fidelity to the actual
physical situation.
A straight line might
look even nicer, but
it wouldn't be accurate.
So when we think about
evaluating a model, what we
really should be asking, I
think, are two questions.
One is fidelity.
And another way to think about
that is credibility.
Typically, we're creating a
model because we don't know
the actual answer.
And we're trying to see what
might actually happen if we,
say, ran a physical
experiment.
And so we have to ask the
question of, do we believe the
results the model
are giving us.
And so that sort of boils down
to not a question of
mathematics, but a question
of reasoning.
Can we look at the model
and convince
ourselves that it is accurate?
And the other question
is utility.
And I can think about that as,
in some sense, what questions
are answerable with the model?
So the first one is pretty much
a question of personal
preference.
And for this particular
simulation, which is pretty
simple, or this particular
model, it's hard to argue that
one is more believable
than the other.
I might argue the second is more
believable, because it's
a direct implementation of
the physical system.
I didn't rely on my
math being right.
But the math is pretty
simple here.
What's, I think, more apparent
is in this case there is some
additional utility offered
by the simulation model.
And it's often true of that,
simulation models, that we can
ask what-if questions, because
we can easily change the model
to be slightly different in ways
that is usually harder
for an analytic model.
For example, suppose these
drug molecules had this
peculiar property that every
100 time steps, they could
clone themselves.
And so every molecule that was
there became two molecules.
Unlikely for the drug.
Not so unlikely for, say, a
bacterium or a virus, as
you've seen.
Well, a little hard to figure
out how to do the
probabilities in the case that
that happens, because we'll no
longer get this beautiful,
simple exponential decay.
But quite easy to think about
how we would change the
simulation model, which is
what I have done here.
So I said here, if time is not
equal to 0 and time is evenly
divisible by 100, then I'm
just going to double the
number of molecules.
Every living molecule
will clone itself.
And now we'll see what we get.
Well, we get this rather
peculiar-looking sawtooth
distribution.
We still have, overall,
an exponential decay.
But we see every once in
while it jumps up, and
then it comes down.
It's not so easy to write a
simple closed-form formula
that describes this, but very
easy to produce a simulation
model that gives you
some insight to
what's happening here.
And that's, I think, one of
the great attractions of
simulation modeling, is we get
to do this sort of thing.
Many, many physical systems
exhibit exponential decay or
exponential growth.
For example, people in Japan
now are very interested in
half-life of various radioactive
particles.
And when we talk about
half-life, we mean that there
is exponential decay
in radioactivity.
That's what half-life is.
So people are looking at what
is the half-life of iodine,
say, versus other radioactive
particles.
We also see exponential
growth a lot.
I used to have a swimming pool
which I had to maintain, and I
realized if I let the algae
get out of control in the
pool, it went from having very
little algae to having a lot
of algae very quickly,
because the algae
doubles every period.
And so all of a sudden,
it takes off.
So exponential growth is--
exponential decay are
important things.
We see them all the time.
People use the word very
carelessly when they mean
quick growth.
They say exponential.
But of course, it has a
very specific meaning.
OK.
We've now, for the moment at
least, finished our short
venture into probability
and distributions.
We'll come back to it a little
bit when we talk about how to
lie with statistics.
But before we do that, before
we leave probability for a
while, just for fun, I want to
pose to you one of these
probability problems that
hurts people's heads.
It's a very popular one.
How many people here
have heard of
the Monty Hall problem?
OK, a lot of you.
So as we play the game, those
of you who know the answer,
I'll ask your forbearance
not to blurt it out.
So it's a wonderful problem.
It's so exciting that people
have written books about it.
So here's how it works.
This is from a game show called,
I think, Let's Make a
Deal, with the host, Monty
Hall, who did it forever.
So the way it works is you
start with three doors.
Behind one of the doors
is a great prize--
for example, an automobile.
Behind each of the other
doors is a booby
prize, typically a goat.
I don't know why people don't
like goats, but apparently
they don't.
So the way it works is Monty
invites someone from the
audience, chosen on the basis of
their outlandish costumes.
And they come down and they're
told what wonderful prize is
behind one of the doors.
And then they're asked
to choose a door.
So the person might choose a
door and say, I'll choose door
number one.
Monty then opens one of
the other two doors.
He knows which doors have
the goats and which
door has the car.
He opens a door with the goat.
So now there are
two doors left.
And he asks the contestant,
do you want to switch.
Do you want to stick with door
one or would you like to
switch to door two?
And the Monty Hall problem
is, what should she do?
And the audience will always
shout out advice.
So I do have a simulation
of that.
I'd like to run.
I need three people to volunteer
to be doors.
Come on, three doors.
It's not so hard.
Come on down.
And I need one person to
volunteer to be the contest.
Is anybody in a costume here?
I don't know.
Mitch is kind of in one, but--
all right.
These are the contestants.
All right, you're
door number (2).
You're door number (1).
You are door number (3).
A contestant please.
There's $1 in one of these.
You can actually win
something of value.
All right, we have a contestant
coming down.
Oh, all right, we have two
contestants coming down.
All right.
The aisle wins.
All right, choose a door.
You choose door number (2).
All right, let us open
door number (1).
And let's see what's
in door number (1).
Show it to the class.
It is a goat.
Now you have a choice.
You can stick with your original
decision, or you can
switch to door number (3).
Suggestions?
AUDIENCE: Switch.
AUDIENCE: Lower one.
AUDIENCE: Don't switch it.
AUDIENCE: Switch.
PROFESSOR: All right.
She is going to stick with
door number (2).
Let us open door number (2).
She wins $1.
It is yours.
Don't spend it all at once.
Thank you, everybody.
All right, now, was she
lucky or was she
smart, is the question?
Does it matter?
This was a subject of enormous
debate in the
mathematical community.
In 1991, Parade magazine
published a correct solution
to the problem, and
approximately 10,000 readers,
including a 1,000 with PhDs in
mathematics, wrote to Parade
telling them they had published
the wrong solution.
And the debate roiled on.
So who thinks she was lucky
and who thinks it actually
matters whether you switch?
Who thinks it matters, those
who don't know the problem?
Who thinks it doesn't matter?
All right.
The doesn't-matters win
by a small margin.
And in fact, that's what the
readers of Parade thought.
But they were wrong.
It matters a lot whether
you switch.
Let's do the analysis first,
analytically, and then we'll
do a simulation.
So the player makes a choice.
And this is some interesting
ways to think about
probability.
And with the probability of 1/3,
the player has chosen the
correct door.
All right?
Now that means that with a
probability of 2 out of 3, the
car lies behind one of
the other two doors.
Now here's the key step.
Monty opens a door that
he knows does
not contain the prize.
The key thing to notice here is
the choice of doors is not
independent of the choice of the
player, because Monty will
never choose the door that the
player has initially picked.
Now since the probability of the
prize being behind the two
remaining doors is 2 out of 3,
the probability of the prize
being behind one of the doors
that he did not open
is 2 out of 3 --
in fact, behind the
other door.
In fact, you were
extraordinarily lucky to win
the dollar, because switching
doubles the odds of winning.
Because remember, your odds of
winning were 1 out of 3 when
you first chose the door.
That left two doors.
The probability of the car being
behind one of those two
doors was 2/3.
Monty opened the one that
didn't contain the car,
because he knew it
contained a goat.
So that must mean the
probability of the car being
behind the remaining
door is 2 out of 3.
So you double your
odds of winning.
The logic is kind of clear.
It didn't stop people from
aggressively debating it for
the longest of times.
And I kind of didn't
believe it myself.
So I did what I usually do,
is I wrote some code.
And let's look at two
pieces of code here.
And again, the theme here is
how we can use simulation
models to understand slightly
complex, or more than slightly
complex, situations.
So here's the way
the game works.
So I've got a simple simulation
that counts the
number of wins.
And the way it's done is, for
t in range number of trials,
the contestant picks 1,
2, or 3 at random.
I've tried to mimic
exactly the game.
So the car is behind
one of the doors.
The contestant guesses a door.
And then there's this
'choose' function to
open one of the two.
And we're going to have
2 ways of choosing
which door gets opened.
So the Monty Hall way--
Monty chooses.
He takes the guessed door and
the prize door, and he opens
the non-guess that contains
the goat.
So if (1) is the guessed door,
and (1) is not the guessed
door and it's not the prize
door, then he opens (1).
Same thing for (2).
And if (1) or (2) is not the
choice, he opens (3).
As opposed to the random choose
function, which just
chooses at random between the
doors that weren't guessed.
So it might open the car, at
which point the contest is
told, sorry, you lose,
you don't even
have a choice anymore.
We're then going to run the
simulation with Monty choosing
and random choice, and
see what we get.
So you've got the code on
the handout to do this.
I'm not going to go
over the details.
The thing to notice about it is
it's yet another example of
how we can use PyLab to do
some interesting plots.
This time I'm going to print a
pie chart, just to show that
we can do those.
And let's see what happens.
So people understand
what's going on?
That I've got these two
functions, montyChoose and
randomChoose.
I'm using those functions as
parameters, a very convenient
thing, and running the
simulation each way.
And let's see what happens.
All right.
So what we see here is, when I
run montyChoose, sure enough,
it comes out to about 2/3 of
the time, you win if you
change, and only 1/3 of the
time if you don't, pretty
close to what the
math predicts.
In fact, sort of astonishingly
close.
On the other hand, if Monte
had been just choosing at
random, then we see it really
doesn't matter whether you
switch or not.
So again, from a probability
point of view, we see how
subtle these things can be based
upon whether decisions
are independent of previous
decisions, or not independent.
And we also see, in some sense,
that we can write a
very small piece of code that
actually provides a simulation
of a real, in this case, game,
and we can have, I think, a
lot of confidence.
We can look at the code and say,
is it really the way the
game is described?
Yes.
And then we get nice results
that tell us what to do.
And in this case it tells us
that, if Monty is choosing
based upon what he knows,
then by all
means, you should switch.
And I'm sorry that it didn't
work out that way when we
played the game, but that's
the way probabilities are,
that you didn't switch
and you lucked out.
So now you're a rich lady.
All right.
So that's one thing we can do.
One more thing I want to talk
about, before we leave the
subject of Monte Carlo
simulations--
it's pretty clear that these
kind of simulations are very
useful for tackling problems
in which predictive
non-determinism plays a role.
And at first blush, you might
think that, OK, that's the
only time we should use a Monte
Carlo simulation, when
there's some inherent randomness
in the problem, and
therefore it's hard to model
analytically, and therefore
we'll use randomness
in the code.
Interestingly enough,
particularly in recent years,
but for quite a while, people
have understood the notion of
using randomized algorithms
to solve problems in which
randomness plays no role.
And that's a little surprising,
but an incredibly
useful concept to put in your
bag of tricks, the ability to
use randomization to solve
problems that are not random.
So let me talk about
an example.
Consider the concept of pi.
Pi has been around
for a long time.
For thousands of years,
people have known
that there's a constant--
called pi since about
the 18th century--
associated with circles, such
that the circumference of a
circle is always going
to be equal to
pi times the diameter.
The area of a circle is
always going to be pi
r-squared, et cetera.
So for thousands of years,
people knew that there was
such a constant.
They just didn't know
what it was.
And there's a long and beautiful
history of people
attempting to estimate pi.
About the earliest estimate
I've found is from the
Egyptians, in something called
the Rhind Papyrus, from 1650
BC, or thereabouts.
And it estimated pi
to be 4 times--
let me get this right--
8/9 squared, which is
3.16, more or less.
That was pretty good.
About a 1,000 years later,
an estimate of pi
appears in the Bible.
Or at least, it's implied by the
Bible in a description of
one of Solomon's construction
projects.
It says, "And he made a molten
sea, 10 cubits from the one
brim to the other.
It was round all about, and his
height was five cubits.
And a line of 30 cubits did
compass it round about."
So you can take that and solve
for pi, because you've given
the circumference, and other
details, the diameter.
You can solve for pi.
And you see, if you do that, pi
comes out to be exactly 3.
Not quite as accurate
as the Egyptians
had 1,000 years earlier.
Now perhaps the Bible
is wrong.
I don't want to offend
anybody.
Or perhaps the molten sea wasn't
perfectly circular.
Or maybe the circumference was
measured from the wall outside
and the diameter from
the inside.
Or maybe it was just that was a
good enough number to use in
construction, because a cubit
was something like the length
of your forearm.
Different people have different
length forearms, and
there was no reason to try
and be more precise.
Who knows?
The best estimate of pi in
ancient times was from
Archimedes of Syracuse.
And he did something quite
amazing for around 200 BC.
He didn't give the
value of pi.
He said, I don't know what the
value is, but I can give you
an upper bound and
a lower bound.
And he did this by carefully
constructing a polygon with a
huge number of tiny little
straight lines that would
approximate a circle, and then
actually measuring things.
So he built a polygon with 96
sides, and concluded that pi
was somewhere between 223
divided by 71, and 22/7.
Very sophisticated at the time,
to be giving upper and
lower bounds.
If we look at what the middle
of that is, it's actually
amazingly good.
It's 3.1418.
Not bad.
All right.
What does this have to do with
Monte Carlo simulations?
Many years later--
in fact, in the 1700s, two
French mathematicians invented
another way of computing pi.
Buffon and Laplace.
Actually Buffon first
proposed it.
He got it wrong.
Laplace corrected it.
And they said, we can find pi
using a stochastic simulation.
They didn't use those words,
but that's what
they basically described.
And they talked about it in
terms of needle-dropping.
So think about having a square,
and inscribing in the
square a circle.
And you'll excuse my lack
of artistic ability.
So they put one of those
on the floor.
And then they dropped needles,
which would get carried around
by the wind and land in
some random place.
And they counted the number of
needles that landed in the
circle, and the number of
square but not in the circle.
And then they did
a little math.
Let's assume for the sake of
argument here that the radius
of the circle is 1.
They observed the following
equation must hold, that the
needles in the circle over the
needles in the square should
be equal to the area of the
circle divided by the area of
the square.
It seems logical, if they're
landing at random, that they
would get distributed
proportional to the area.
And then they solved for pi,
knowing that the area of the
circle is pi r-squared.
They could then say that pi--
in fact, in this case, since we
know the radius is 1, and 1
squared is 1, that tells us that
the area of the circle
should be pi, right?
Pi times 1.
So they said pi is equal to the
area of the circle, which
is equal to the area of the
square times the needles in
the circle, divided by the
needles in the square.
So they had that formula.
Unfortunately they couldn't drop
enough needles to get a
very good estimate.
So they described
how to do it.
But this was an experiment.
They did the math, they
had a nice formula.
They did not have an
experimental apparatus that
would actually let them drop
enough needles to get a very
good estimate.
It would take a lot
of patience.
And maybe they wouldn't
land at random.
Who knows what.
Fortunately, today, we have a
much easier way to do that.
So we can write some code that
does the simulation.
We're going to have
a way to throw the
needles or drop the needles.
And then what we're going to
do is we're going to have a
simulation that we're going
to run, that's going to--
I don't know how many
needles to drop.
I'm going to keep dropping
needles until I get a small
enough standard deviation that I
can be confident that I have
a bound on pi with some
confidence interval.
In fact, I'm going to use 5%
here, and use that rule of
thumb that Mitch talked about
last time, about standard
deviations.
And I say, all right, I'm going
to keep running the
experiment until the standard
deviation of
trials is 5% or less.
Two standard deviations is small
enough that I get my
answer within some precision.
I'm going to ask here for
a precision of 0.01.
And so therefore my standard
deviation should be that
precision divided by 4, because
I'm looking for 2
standard deviations on either
side of the mean, which is why
I'm dividing by 4
and not by 2.
So I divide by 4 and
I see what I get.
So let's run it.
And this will take a
little bit of time.
It will take no time if I don't
uncomment the code to
actually run the experiment.
Estimate pi.
And we'll get some estimates.
So what we can see here is that
my estimates change as I
run experiments.
Every time I run this-- or not
every time, I often get a
different number of
needles I need.
But you can see that my first
estimate is not very good.
My estimates do get
better, though not
monotonically better.
But what does get monotonically
better is the
standard deviation gets smaller
and smaller, which is
what you would expect.
So there's no guarantee that by
running a bigger trial, I
get a more accurate result.
What there is a guarantee
is that I can have more
confidence in my result.
I could have gotten lucky and
run a small number of needles
and gotten it exactly
right by chance.
But I would have been wrong to
assume it was right, because
let's pretend we didn't
know what the value
of pi was, a priori.
But what I can say here is since
my standard deviation is
now 0.002, and if we look at
it, we'll see that these
things are normally distributed,
I can be pretty
sure that the true value of pi
is 3.1407 et cetera, plus or
minus 0.00023, et cetera,
with a 95% confidence.
So this is using the stuff
that you saw in the last
lecture to now combine that
statistical background with
this simulation to compute
a pretty darn
good estimate of pi.
And if I ran more needles, if I
wanted to get more precise,
I can get as precise as I want
to be, as many digits of
precision as I want.
So again, what we see here is
that we've been able to solve
a problem that had nothing
to do with randomness.
The value of pi is not
a random number.
And yet we used randomness
to solve it.
A very common technique.
And we use some very simple
statistics to know whether or
not we should believe
our solution.
And so those are the
two lessons I
want you to take home.
Now if you look at your handout,
you'll see that at
the bottom, I've used the same
technique to do integration.
If you think about what
integration means, when you
ask, what is the integral of
some formula, what you learned
when you first looked at
calculus was that that was the
area under some curve, right?
That's what the integral is.
And you learned all sorts of
complicated mathematics to
solve complicated integrals.
Well, you can pose an
integration problem exactly
analogous to this.
You draw your curve.
You drops some needles.
You count how many fall under
the curve, how many don't fall
under the curve in
some larger area.
And you can solve
the integration.
And that's exactly what I've
done here, where f is the
function being integrated.
I won't go through
the details.
Now in fact, this kind of
simulation is not a good way
to solve single integrals.
It's much better to use
something like Simpson's rule,
whatever that is.
But in fact, it is frequently
used in practice for more
complicated things, a double or
triple integration, where
the mathematics gets
fairly complicated.
People will often solve those
problems using a Monte Carlo
simulation.
It's a practical method
for tackling it.
And again, in your handout,
you'll see a very simple piece
of code that does a
double integral.
All right.
That's all for today.